drôle d'endroit pour une rencontre il ne
s'agit pas de studio de télévision mais
d'un parking c'est là que vous vous
rencontrer catherine deneuve gérard
depardieu dans ce film qui sort demain
et qui est signée par françois dupeyron
un film dont vous êtes heureux
l'un et l'autre oui fut normalement mais
très heureux en ce qui me concerne et je
ne dirait pas le contraire non plus
alors on est presque déjà dans vos dans
la lenteur de vos réponses dans
l'ambiance de ce film troisième plus
long très étrange et je vous propose
d'en voir un extrait un parking au bord
de l'autoroute une femme que l'on jette
un homme qui bien sûr c'est le début du
film n'en veut pas
basta
dans la poule longtemps j'ai pas
renouveler une femme se confirme sans la
poule la poule de luxe
alors c'est un film étrange parce qu'on
dirait presque du théâtre unité de lieu
unité d'action unité de temps c'est ça
qu'il voulait attirer l'un et l'autre
dans ce scénario gerra qui m'a intéressé
c'est de voir d'abord c'est de voir un
drôle de couple
enfin un rôle de femme et puis par la
même occasion un couple derrière c'est
vrai que le théâtre aussi jeune et
j'adore le théâtre et puis je trouvais
que c'était difficile de rendre une
autoroute de essayé de parler de
l'intimité sur des gens qui parce qu'ils
traversent
voilà moi c'est ce qui aurait pu
m'arrêter parce que j'ai jamais fait de
théâtre et fait quelque chose que je
redoute beaucoup mais en même temps je
reconnais que quand j'ai lu le scénario
c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup fait signe
vers l'histoire c'était ces deux
personnages épinglé la nuit cet homme
qui allait repousser cette femme
longtemps d'abord parce qu'une femme qui
s'est jetée comme ça dans un an mais on
est seul on a décidé de s'attaquer à une
chose concrète qui est moderne voiture
c'est ça fait désordre et puis ça ne les
empêche de travailler c'est vrai et cet
homme va être très résistant d'ailleurs
la presse dans cette femme mais ce qui
me plaisait surtout c'était je crois à
l'idée de m'affronter avec avec gérard
dans la même direction c'est à dire de
s'engager dans quelque chose je savais
que j'aurais besoin de lits et je savais
que j'aurais pu que je pouvais l'aider
qu'on allait avoir un vrai tête-à-tête
parce que j'ai réagi tourné plusieurs
fois avec lui on a eu des très belles
scènes mais on n'a jamais tourné aussi
longuement ensemble
alors justement on sent dans ce film une
extraordinaire complicité entre vous qui
est presque plus une complicité je
dirais de deux coffres de stature plus
que de tempérament alors c'est vrai
c'est votre cinquième film ensemble
c'est parce que vous ne connaissez bien
ou pas ce que vous
mérité l'autre d'une certaine manière la
notion de mérite ou pas mais je sais que
j'ai l'impression qu'on est assez
complémentaire
même physiquement je dire
physiologiquement comme ça je trouve que
quand on nous voit ensemble à l'écran il
ya quelque chose de complémentaire
non pas qu'il soit fort et que moi je
sois fragile mais gérard à l'adresse
l'avait plus fort et plus oui c'est plus
souterrain que ça mais disons que a
priori à l'avant-première premières
impressions oui et après moi j'ai des
brutalités ou des brusqueries comme ça
que gérard n'a pas géré à une voie
beaucoup plus douce avec des inflexions
beaucoup plus que moi
moi je peux être même sèche parfois et
je trouve que ça fait une musique un peu
différente ça n'arrivait à vrai couple
comme ça sur au cinéma ou même dans la
vie des saints dans la viseur de rennes
c'est difficile mais aussi des masses
est très rare alors justement cinq films
déjà ensemble et vous êtes vous est
consacré le couple mythique du cinéma
français donc ça veut dire que pour
notre plus grand bonheur tous vous allez
continuer longtemps et plusieurs fois ça
ce sera la réalité du jugement final qui
qu'il décidera mais après c'est vrai que
c'est très agréable de se retrouver sur
un sur un film comme celui là avec des
rouleaux s'y déroulent aussi fort et
fizi tournage de nuit c'est très
particulier comment bien on vit
actuellement une femme avec eux que l'on
a envie de partager quelque chose au
cinéma c'est vrai et le couple mythique
vous vous trouvez bien assortis moi je
m'appelle couple mythique reine ne pas
parler ne pas se montrer ne pas venir la
télévision fallait faire sur les écrans
et ne plus ne plus apparaître les
couples mythiques sûr que c'est des
choses qui l'idée de a priori de faire
rêver sur une image de coupe qui en plus
une image sont assez moderne et assez
réalistes même très cruel c'est une idée
qui me plaît beaucoup
en tout cas je le dis tout net vous êtes
l'un et l'autre éblouissant dans ce film
donc drôle d'endroit pour une rencontre
un film qui sort de ma très vite